and I think one of the sort of aha
moments that I've had over the past
couple of years is how much we as women
have been lied to about almost
everything if anyone mentions anything
about women or anything about sisters
sisters will say well what about the men
well what about the brothers it's like
we can't take accountability we can't be
honest with ourselves the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam treated his
wives well he treated them fairly he
treated them justly he was kind he was
generous he was loving he was
affectionate he was all of those things
right but his purpose in life was not to
keep his wives happy the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam never said to
men that they will be judged upon the
pleasure of their wife or the pleasing
of their wife they will be judged upon
their treatment of their wives
[Music]
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a Saturday for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
you and a shall be repeal the Lord click
the link and donate what you can
assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah before
I start I want to praise Allah the most
merciful the most trust or Praises glory
and gratitude belong to him we have an
amazing honorable dear sister
subhanallah sister
I got that right
um so we've got our sister here
and we are going to shall be talking
about
issues pertaining to gender roles but
inshallah we're going to be reacting to
two videos
um one of sister Neymar's videos which
actually went viral we're gonna find out
why did it go viral and specifically
with the red book red pill Community it
went viral then we're going to react to
a video of myself uh changing my
daughter that putting her clothes on Etc
um and we're going to react to it as
well so we're going to be covering two
extremes here today inshallah
um and we will come there which is
feminism and red pill but uh yeah sister
neighbor please tell us for those who do
not know you a bit about yourself
inshallah
um and also there is a something you've
got an announcement that you want to
make as well inshallah and Robin says
you guys are watching at home myself and
sister Neymar are working on a project
inshallah which will help young we're
not just young single Muslims into the
marriage seeking process which will be
launched inshallah at the end of June
keep an eye out for that inshallah but
before that we'll get into our last
straight to Sister Neymar so assistant
Neymar tell us what do you have coming
up and also tell us a bit about yourself
it's wonderful to be here on my on this
platform it's my first time so I'm
really really pleased to be here
alhamdulillah
um for those of you who don't know me my
name is Naima B Robert I'm an
award-winning author of over 30 books
for children teens and adults and
alhamdulillah I get to coach women
mainly but some brothers as well to be
able to share their story Message or
knowledge in a book Insha'Allah so I'm
working with sisters at the moment
um information about that will be in the
description inshallah so if you would
like to know more about that please do
follow the link in the description
um but for now you know aside from the
book writing aside from the coaching
alhamdulillah I get to present I get to
speak
um and get to be an entrepreneur and uh
you know I have 100 five children and I
get to be a homeschooling homesteading
mom as well alhamdulillah so that's a
little bit about me and my YouTube
channel has lots more about the stuff
that we talk about lots of marriage
conversations over there but we'd love
to see you guys over there as well
inshallah
inshallah amazing may Allah bless you
preserve you inshallah for that
alhamdulillah for the service that
you're doing to the ummah which is one
of the biggest threats that we have
today is divorce uh and inshallahu said
um we will be working with sister Neymar
uh to combat these issues inshallah
um and yeah in Charlotte in a couple of
months we'll be launching a an app uh
which will inshallah cater for that so
I'm going to get straight into it let's
get straight to this video so you had
this video which went viral I'm gonna
play it uh well let's play it in
Charlotte that people see I'm gonna come
back and see what was the hype what was
the hype about inshallah are you ready
sure yep let's go
if you have to convince a sister a woman
that you are a good option that you're
her best option right by jumping through
hoops by proving Yourself by buying her
stuff by telling her what she wants to
hear
she's not the one for you that's what I
tell my sons why do I say that because
she clearly does not see you as her best
option right she thinks you're just one
of many or maybe you're okay but maybe
another better one is coming right now
if you finally convince her to marry you
what is going to happen in that
relationship what's going to be the
power dynamic in that relationship yep
you've basically signed up for a life of
her on a pedestal and you working
overtime to please her and sisters
unfortunately hate it when I talk about
this right because this is the model
we've been presented by society and
man's job is to please you a man's job
is to make sure you are happy a man's
job is to cater to you Etc yeah and
the reality is certainly as far as the
dean is concerned it's actually opposite
um
Allah and the prophet sallam have taught
us as women the importance of
pleasing our husbands of catering to our
husbands of looking after our husbands
okay
so you you heard that for yourself
brother and sisters I'm gonna press like
for that video or actually I've really
liked it I'm gonna like I'm just I'm
gonna like it again uh okay so it looks
inside Okay so
I think
there was a lot of truths there that was
spoken uh one thing that I want to touch
upon so what
I mean tell us a bit about like that
podcast Etc but besides that
for those who are watching at home some
sisters might be very upset you know why
why did you have to say that so I'm
going to come to my perspective of it uh
because
I come from a different angle but tell
us a bit more let's just you know if you
can just elaborate a little bit more
about what you said there
sure sure
obviously this clip was in the context
of a very long conversation masha'allah
and I we were talking about lots of
different things and we got to this
particular point in the conversation and
I think one of the the sort of aha
moments that I've had over the past
couple of years is how much we as women
have been lied to
about almost everything right
um about our role about what value we
bring about what our priorities are
about the roles that we should play in
you know all our relationships
um and a lot a huge part of that is the
Disney Hollywood Bollywood uh you know
romance music Etc industry that has
taught us a model right and now in our
heads that is the ideal model that is
the model of the ideal relationship what
is it the ideal relationship is where
the man is chasing and where he's he's
trying to prove himself and is
constantly working to make you happy
make you happy make you happy and the
most important aspect of that
relationship is how you feel in that
relationship now lots of sisters will
say well what's wrong with a man making
his wife happy and lots of comments I
mean the videos had over three million
views I've never ever had a video go
crazy like that before but it's so mad
to me how you look through those
comments every man is saying that's the
truth that is exactly what it's like you
will work your you will work yourself to
the Bone for a woman
and she still won't see you right or
you'll try you know if you're jumping
through hoops or whatever she doesn't
want you or she's you know all of these
things and so many men are like that is
what happens that is exactly what
happens and of course the women are
feeling attacked and feeling on you know
they go on the defensive and they're
like well why does it have to be one way
what's wrong with a man proving himself
now before I kind of go into uh the
other side of it because it was with you
know the Islamic side of it
you know one of the things that a lot of
people did and I noticed online
women slash sisters we do this all the
time if anyone mentions anything about
women or anything about sisters women
sisters will say well what about the men
well what about the brothers you know
why why do you know it's like we can't
take accountability we can't be honest
with ourselves and eat others and action
no no it's it's it's it's really it's
something that's quite amazing for me to
see right you you're being told
something and the thing is the the um
the idea that you know because so many
people said you know like in Islam it's
not like that you know the husband and
wife should cater to each other Etc and
I had this conversation with some more
sisters who are much more knowledgeable
than me right and I I asked them you
know was I wrong in what I said because
from what I know from the Quran and the
Sunnah the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam treated his wives well he
treated them fairly he treated them
justly he was kind he was generous he
was loving he was affectionate he was
all of those things right
but his purpose in life was not to keep
his wise happy
because if that had been his purpose he
would have failed because guess what
ain't no woman happy all the time and
some women and sisters we know this
right we know this because we we're
living in this body we're living in this
mind right
one day he does something lovely for you
it makes it's like the whole world
becomes a paradise right two weeks later
catch you in a different site you know a
season of your cycle he does the same
thing and you've got the ick you're like
oh why is he always doing that or why
didn't he do this instead so sisters
sisters ladies we need to be honest with
ourselves as well the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam never
said to men that they will be judged
upon the pleasure of their wives or the
pleasing of their wives they will be
judged upon their treatment of their
wives right because that's something
that's quantifiable all right something
that is it's it's just to judge somebody
upon that basis but if we start to go
into the Hadith that mention the value
of pleasing your husband of catering to
your husband sisters get triggered they
don't want to hear it and unfortunately
the reason why we don't want to hear it
is because we have imbibed this idea
that we're equals we're Partners like
you know we're supposed to have the same
say and you know basically everything is
the same and Islam is you know gender
equality and feminine you know Islam is
a feminist religion and Islam did this
and Islam did that Islam did this yes
there are aspects of Islam that you
could say this is pro-woman but there
are other aspects of Islam that the man
has the upper hand and that is because
Allah designed a system and if we as
women are not happy to play our part in
this system the system is not going to
work so I don't want to go too long
about this and kind of rant and Rave
about it but that was one of the things
I saw coming through that sisters can't
stand to hear that their husband has a
right over there they don't want to hear
it because they're just like no no no
what about the husband what does he have
to do what if he does this so what if
he's like that what it is like this
never realizing that hold on a minute
sis Allah is actually going to question
you about how you treated your husband
he's actually going to question you
about how pleased he was with you and
that is not this it's not the reverse
and again any Scholars or students of
knowledge out there who know that my
interpretation is incorrect please reach
out to me because I tried to see is this
equal is it literally in the eyes of
Allah is equal and from what I can see
it's not there is a hierarchy and if we
can't be comfortable with that we are
going to be butting heads again and
again with the dean and butting heads
with the dean is always going to be a
losing battle
yeah I think you know like mashallah
bless you um that's the issue because at
the end of the day it's a responsibility
that is given to us so the
responsibility is so hi that of course
that's the reason why for example our
wives are going to be asked like for
example like the Hadith for the person
tell them that if a woman who prays a
Salah and does the basics Etc and her
husband is pleased with her she can
enter Jannah I think it says it through
any door somewhere along those lines so
why so this is this is a fact and this
is something that submission to Islam is
very simple you submit it you have to
submit to it now system might be
thinking oh but why hold on a second
there are so many things that as men we
are told to do that we submit to they
remember things that don't make it seem
as if Allah is telling you to do things
that you don't like for example be
polygamy be it this obedience the
husband and not going out without the
Possible's permission there is reasons
why Allah specific protocols in place
when it comes to a woman because the
studies that show that a woman can be
easily manipulated so there's so many
things Allah has put in place to protect
you so for us for example as men yeah I
mean if you think about it that
protecting providing when there's a war
like look at Ukraine there's an outright
War there's all the most of the women
have left the men are there dying
literally these men are dying they are
dying that people these women again
focusing your husband died yeah you just
got sure he's dead by the way yeah so
the thing is here is that it's because
of that Allah has given the man One
Direction above the woman so it's so
many responsibility that is on the
shoulders of a man that's the reason why
that if you like the prophet saws said
that if I was to ask anybody to
prostrate to anybody it will be the wife
to the husband now when we say this
Allah says think my husband who doesn't
give me my rights my husband who cheats
on me my husband who doesn't provide
yeah yeah no not that husband not not
that husband knowing that because they
say your husband who violates you as a
Muslim woman you have a right to ask for
divorce if you catch him being disloyal
and when I'm in disloyed I'm not talking
about polygamy I'm talking about this
loyal and full of this loyal or he
doesn't provide all other things I don't
want to get into now but there's you
have right so Islam is giving you those
rights but you need to understand that
that is the responsibility that we have
which is so like it's it's what we have
is not something that we enjoy you know
it's hard to provide and protect but
yeah
no I just you know I I would like to
just pause on that point that you made
about sisters saying oh the husband who
does this and the husband who does that
it's like we when it comes to men
when it comes to Brothers
sisters don't give any Grace
there's no rahma
and they always I find the narrative is
always either the lowest common
denominator or the worst case scenario
let me tell you something yeah
I've worked with thousands of women now
mashallah
out of those thousands of women that
I've worked with in all different
capacities there's a minority whose
husbands are yeah not not giving one
needs to be gave okay they are not
fulfilling their responsibilities in
that and the eyes of Allah right
the majority are average
the majority of Muslim husbands that I
know of and again come for me in the
comments if you think that I'm way off
the majority of us are average Seekers
which trying our best now
when I say trying your best as a man and
I say this on the podcast what is the
Baseline with regards to your marriage
as a man as you said protect provide try
to be a good example look after your
family bro like that's that's what's
required okay be a man look after your
family now unfortunately for us women
we're complicated beings okay we don't
judge people the way that Allah judges
people we judge according to our whole
host of other criteria that Allah never
mentioned right
oh is he romantic you know does he give
you gifts does he compare to so-and-so's
husband you know is he optimizing his
financial status you know has he bought
you a new car in the last five years all
of these material things all of these
personal emotional things you're using
those criteria to judge your husband and
find him lacking and and again I I don't
think I'm overstating the case when I
say that our generation and the one
coming after we have been bred to have
disdain for men okay even if we're
married to them even if we have husbands
fathers Sons even a lot of women today
suffer from disdain for men and if it's
not disdain and distaste then it is
distrust okay we don't have respect for
men we don't
right we look at our husband who's
working in the kitchen right in his in
his work he's a chef
and he and the subhanallah when you
listen to men that that's why a lot of
sisters are kind of upset with me or
they got upset with me last year because
I assist you've changed like you used to
be so Pro the sisters you used to give
those brothers and tell it like it was
why have you changed why are you always
siding with the brothers and I say
I'm Pro ummah that's what I'm Pro I Am
pro ummah I'm pro-family I'm Pro the
Next Generation right and that means
that some of us sisters are gonna have
to sit down and listen and some of those
brothers are gonna have to sit down and
listen because this is not about us it's
not about us and our egos and you know
our dreams that we've got for ourselves
as individuals because as soon as you
join with another human being the Allah
joined chose for you to join with and
chose to bless you with kids it's not
about you anymore it's about the unit
it's about the family it's about the
Next Generation it's about your legacy
right so
you know this this this this attitude
that I see sisters having and I see it
online especially I don't know how much
of it trickles down into real life to be
honest but online
sisters are out of pocket and they they
do it in a really Sly way especially in
the practicing Community sisters quote
Quran and Hadith in a way that is a dig
at men that is undermining men that is
disrespectful to men as a group right
you know when sisters say we're not here
to worship no man we're here to worship
Allah right we don't care what any man
thinks of us we you know we answer only
to Allah sis you need to understand that
that attitude that you had it's
disrespectful
and a lot of sisters unfortunately
they've got good Dads
they've got nice Brothers
they have a decent husband they've got
sons and they still have this distaste
and distrust and disdain for men
something that we need to recognize
within ourselves and we need to deal
with it because I am so scared when I
hear the way some sisters go online
about men and brothers men brothers and
I think you've got a son
what what are you teaching your son you
know and they'll say oh I'm bringing I'm
bringing up the next generation of men I
said girl you're bitter okay you are
angry and you are bitter and you do not
like men how are you going to teach your
son to be a man if you hate men like how
does it how it doesn't compute
you'll end up showing him how to be a
woman instead of being a man yeah a man
yeah and and yeah yeah
I think yeah it's it's it's like what
you said is very like spun a lot it's
it's so true and and I just see that
because the thing is the there's power
dynamics you know what Allah it's very
interesting I find interesting that for
example
usually for a woman her biological clock
it's around like 30 onwards for a man it
isn't and I believe Allah power dynamics
in place because you need to understand
for the age of 18 to about 28 26 she's
sought after like men are just
she has a pool of men to choose from for
a man it's not I mean there's not really
that show this as well so the power
dynamics change because I believe if
Allah allowed the woman's biological
clock to be 40 50 there will be chaos
they'll be fitment in the land yeah and
now the people in my thinking this what
do you mean by that what I mean is that
for example that by the get-go as a
woman you are valued you are born with
value and I'm not talking about this red
talk forget this nonsense when I'm
talking when I'm using certain
terminology I'm not talking about that
I'm saying you are born with a value as
men we have to gain that working provide
them even up but now I'm ready to get
married I'm trying to say so and even
then a woman I have to propose I have to
speak to the father I have to give the
Mahal after that's improving yourself
that's you proving yourself exactly so
so the thing is here protecting
improvised so all of those elements are
in place so when we say Allah has given
a degree over to a man it's a
responsibility it's not privilege I'll
be honest with you I mean think about it
the the amount of men who are in
dangerous working jobs the amount of men
that you know usually men usually die
much younger than a woman yeah and the
dangerous jobs that they do well going
out even if the thief breaks into the
house there's so many elements where I
could prefer to walk the Biryani all day
every day and you go and do this stuff
but
as a sisters take this as if it's a
privilege like they think oh these these
men Allah has given them privileges
really what privilege yeah yeah yeah
it's it's again it's that feminist lens
it's the feminist lens that stays you
know that power and privilege rather
than responsibility and we don't have to
go to dangerous jobs and War and and
those extremes how many sisters would
honestly sign up to be punished by Allah
for not going praying the Masjid for
five times five times a day yes how many
of us would do that you know let's be
real for a second here right what about
what about even turning your back in war
major sin even to Allah says turning
your back can you imagine sister
nameless sisters don't really understand
this do you know what going to war is
like sometimes by the way we're gonna
have you on the bitter truth show
inshallah when you come back when you
come inshallah into the UK yeah that
when I talk about the issue of the
polygamy like she said yeah I understand
I understand even the best of other the
Believers yes they were jealous Etc but
the point is this if your husband just
off topic gets married again he's still
in your life you're still alive the
second wife is still alive hopefully if
you don't kill her
um but for a man for example when he
goes to war there is a possibility and
women have rira our Hira is to such a
level that even if we're giving our
daughter's hand in marriage inside we're
like
um
even this marriage is
that we have so imagine us going to war
knowing I might die have a limb cut off
I don't know
have a disability whatever it may be or
if I die you are gonna marry somebody
else
is given to men because it's something
for us to at least be motivated towards
we're going to war okay you know what um
because my wife's gonna get married to
somebody else my kids are going to go
out all these elements I'm gonna say
hold on okay
I'm trying to say it's it's it's just
it's like Allah knows us yeah and this
and this is the thing right this is this
is you just hit the nail on the head
knows how he created us now can the
fitra be corrupted absolutely
right can the
true understanding of who you are
as as as everything right as a man as a
woman as a daughter a son a husband a
wife a brother you know an Imam uh you
know a servant whatever it is right can
our like natural understanding of that
role be corrupted of course it can and
what we need to understand and I hope
that we can try within our community is
to clock on
before the damage that has happened to
Western Society happens to us give me an
example
because we're on the same train
people do not think that because we say
Quran and Sunnah we're not on the same
train as the rest of society we're just
holding on to breaks I would just be a
little bit slower
we're trying to hold on to the breaks
but there's people who are like this
let's go let's say this
you know
is it okay
for a woman to say my husband honored me
when he married me
is that okay
is it okay to say I'm grateful that I am
my husband's wife
is it okay to say my husband blessed me
with children because of him I have
these children is it okay and I'm asking
sisters to like be honest like what
comes up for you when you hear that are
you comfortable with that do you feel
some sort of resistance to that because
if you feel some sort of resistance then
you've got some work to do because
subhanallah I say this all the time
for a decent man to decide to commit to
you and partner with you as his wife and
choose you as the mother of his children
and go out there day in day out what
whatever he's doing thinking only of you
and those kids thinking of only you and
those kids and that house right fighting
whatever battles he needs to fight
because of you and those kids that sis
is an honor okay
by itself
even without the date nights even
without the lovey-dovey take that off
faster than the real love language that
you stop that there is a love language
see you know that's it like for example
sisters think buying flowers if you just
thought to yourself this guy when he
leaves the house to the moment he comes
back and if you saw just because you
don't visually see what he's doing yeah
if you saw you say this is a love
language because he is showing his love
via no man like Andrew takes it he said
that no man goes and says
he said obviously before Islam said him
with a crude way but he said no man goes
out and be like oh let me go and work to
oppress my wife how am I going to press
which man goes like me my friends when
we go out to provide we're doing it
because we love our family we don't want
to say okay I'm going to work hard so
let me see when I go home how am I going
to oppress her today
yeah yeah 100 so so going back to this
um this this gratitude right
unfortunately
within sister circles we we're big on
gratitude right all the coaches all the
speakers all talking about gratitude
gratitude gratitude makes the whole you
know Allah says if you are grateful I
will give you more we're grateful for
the trials of this life we're grateful
for our children and all their trials
and everything but dare say to sisters
be grateful for your husband be grateful
to your husband oh my goodness that's
when everyone's hackles rise that's when
everybody is triggered that's when
everybody goes crazy and my question is
why sis why why are you getting
triggered when you hear the Hadith being
quoted about the majority of women being
in Hell Fire why because of being
ungrateful to their husbands when he
does something he can be all good and
everything can be all good and he does
one thing and you say to him I have
never seen any good from you we also
have to reflect sisters so keep Brother
Ali out of the conversation for now
sister is fear Allah reflect on
yourselves we must reflect on ourselves
the last thing I want to see in our
community is this trend of sisters
quitting their marriages of marriages
ending because sisters are like no no
this is not for me anymore it's not this
it's not that it's not this it's not
giving what needs to be gave sisters
fear Allah because you should not allow
yourself to be used by the shaitaan to
break up a marriage and I know sisters
will say oh your gas lighting you know
there are sisters with genuine problems
what about the brothers who are domestic
violence
you know I'm not talking about them
exactly I don't know why you are not
even in that situation so why are you
bringing that up why do they always
bring that up well I don't understand
I've done a post we're going to react to
one of my videos by the way let's relax
in a minute yeah I've done a video where
I was like in Ramadan and I was like
basically guys so um so I'm giving in
the theater Min so I'm that guy's look I
just came I'm gonna go for a little jog
um just for those men basically my wife
took the car today she was a bit late
the food was going to be a bit late so I
thought you know what instead of like oh
where's my food I'm hungry relax calm
down have some mercy on her uh and I'll
just give it somebody said to the
brothers to be relaxed calm down when it
comes to that and I say look I'm just I
told my wife I'm gonna go for like a
quick joke I'll come back you know even
if it's gone past like half an hour now
I'll have a date it's calm it's not a
big deal
so I never knew this got Twisted in such
a mad way by sisters and in my head I'm
giving this year to the men I'm giving
the to the men I'm not saying
nothing to the sisters all I'm saying is
Nasir to the men be patient with your
wives they can be late
all I see in the comment section
why are you not helping her why do you
cook maybe she's not well maybe she's
ill maybe she's fasting maybe she's this
and I'm thinking they added so many
scenarios to the situation that after
when I came back from jogging I came
back I ate on top of that my wife
actually made up of crumble yeah she
made up of crumble and I was eating
apple crumble yeah I was eating it she
was actually right next to me yeah I was
eating it and then I was I don't know if
you've seen the video I was making a
joke I was like yeah you make sure you
make my food yeah and I was doing this
yeah so and then we was just joking
around yeah and then I said to her on
camera I was like like did you need my
help in the kitchen yeah and as a joke
she goes yeah I did actually yeah and we
both started laughing so the sensitive
human was there and the sister who
messaged this she messaged me later
because she was the main corporate who
started all this year and she was like
and I thought to myself did you guys
it's as if Sister Neymar it's as if they
totally disregarded off this was Ali
working was Alia providing was that
nothing it's as if I was doing nothing
she was doing something I was doing
nothing the fact that I went to leave to
go the joke it was and I said to her
even just so they can understand I even
said to her and she the only thing she
needed for me before I left was she said
my hands are um she actually she was
marinating the meat she said can you get
the lemon why the only thing that is I
cut the lemon and I put the juice on she
told me where to stop like a macho man I
was very natural at that moment when I
put the lemon juice and I felt like a
real man when I was doing it
my wife said that day she actually said
to me I want to cook this specific dish
which takes about two hours she
recommended it so I was like look how
you guys perverted it twisted it as if
I'm the husband that doesn't do nothing
stay at home sleep I came my wife is
like tired I said shut up you shut up
and make me feel like otherwise and then
this scenario and I thought to myself if
my wife didn't have a strong mind she
could have easily cut the Christmas and
go
could have started my wife doesn't like
me in the kitchen she doesn't like me in
the kitchen yeah okay one's actually
like as soon as I tried to wash this is
when she needs help she's tired
and she will come unless you know what
she do I watched this issue go and watch
the same dishes again she go see this
she's like no you didn't do it properly
I said yeah okay you just wasted my time
but the problem is what the point is
what and which video we're going to
react to which ties to this topic will
let's watch this quickly and then we'll
um so this is the video that I've had
this perception where as a Muslim man
that I am like you know this red pill or
this fake persona of Macho that you know
look and I'm just doing this for the
sake of Allah so that you guys don't
understand that when Ellie talks in a
certain way you know Pro polygamy or
this that Etc no no no no I don't know
what perception you have me of as a
husband and I don't need to prove myself
to anybody but I'm doing this reminder
for maybe some husbands who have a
Persona of thinking that a husband like
for example now my wife's getting ready
okay yeah she's getting ready to run a
bit late yeah I'm dressing up my
daughter changing a nappy if needed be
putting her socks on do not ever think
for a second you are less of a man that
this perception of being a man is like
no this is the wife's job no why I don't
believe this any man who is a true man
is somebody who takes care of his family
so the reason I'm just saying this is
because I want you guys and men out
there to do not have the perception that
you know being a macho man is not
helping your wife or you know not
changing the nappies oh I will never do
that while you're weak individual if you
need to help you've got a good wife
alhamdulillah yes okay you help the
household okay inshallah and
in a nutshell the the reason I've done
that video is because I started to
notice this whole red pill thing going a
little bit extreme yeah which is that
and by the way it's not I'm not saying
that every man that doesn't do that is
less of a man what I'm saying is if
somebody feels as if if they can do it
and they have no problem in doing it
they are like oh this I've been seeing
this like people have been comments I'm
thinking like are men really dislike
like brainwashed by The Red Pill to
think and I know people have a
perception of myself with the bitter
truth I'm a bit raw I'm a bit direct Etc
I wanted them to see that side to me
because that side is not a side of the
camera my wife knows me that is Ali in
the house when needed to be do you get
if I see my wife struggling or we need
to go somewhere whatever I will help put
my daughter's shoes clothes
um if I've never brushed my daughter's
hair I don't want to see something I
haven't done I have no problem doing it
but they're probably messy but anyways
the point is what there is no problem me
the one you see Ali who's you know
really you know sounds like a red pill
this we follow Islam and we need to
understand there is another extreme
which is happening now which is Brothers
oh I'm not doing that that's not my job
so what advice would you give to young
men who are maybe
um influenced by The Red Pill
um as as you know as a sister you know
to these young men what advice because I
know what advice I'll give them but it'd
be nice to hear from you but if there's
anything you want to touch on from the
other topic as well please bring it in
it's a really good topic it's a really
important one because I think that a lot
of young men at the moment are kind of
trying to redefine or ReDiscover their
own masculinity right
um that's why you've got so many young
men Muslim and non-muslim sort of
flocking towards hyper masculine men who
talk about being a man and who reflects
like a man and are not afraid of being a
man and not shamed to be a man because
the opposite has been happening for a
very long time right so I I get it
um I think what I would say is
alhamdulillah
we are the this Dean is the golden mean
right this ummah is a balanced ummah so
alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah for the example of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
because if we are we understand the
Sierra in a balanced way not cherry
picking but in a balanced way you'll see
that there is room for the whole
spectrum of masculine and feminine
energy right and masculine and feminine
roles alhamdulillah in the past in the
Persona of the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam you go from the extreme if you
want to call it that from one end which
is you know the leader the strong leader
the the war hero you know the soldier
the one who who instigated punishments
on people the one who punished his wives
yes let's say that you know who whose
hold his wives yo you know this is not
happening you know who who was able to
discipline his people his family his
household and whatever on that one hand
all the way to the other end where the
Prophet saw sallam was humble and he was
self-effacing and he would very often
give up his own Huck because well why
you know what I'm saying you never see
I've never heard or read of a Hadith
where the Prophet saws was lording it
over anyone in his family who was trying
to prove that I have the upper hand that
I am you know I am the man I should you
just don't see that in the prophetic
personality but so that's that's the
thing Brothers out there just learn the
Sira and try to be as close to the the
prophet saws as you can because those
characteristics of rera and humility of
strength and vulnerability or or you
know being in con you know being able to
be emotional as well as being able to be
strong you will find it all there in the
theater but sisters
please stop this habit that you've
developed on cherry picking from the
Sierra to prove your feminist talking
points because it's not befitting it is
not befitting you cannot only mention
when the prophet saws was soft because
he wasn't always soft and you could only
mentioned that the companions that were
you know whatever whatever you want you
know to to kind of portray and not
mention
other instances that were nothing like
that okay
um because all that's happening is
you're convincing yourself in your own
mind that the dean is a particular way
if you want a man like the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam sis you're
going to have to aim to be like
not the boss babe not oh the rich
wealthy Widow who married a younger man
all flex no yeah that's not late the day
babe those kind of sweets
exactly that is
she was a a strong feminine woman that
is what she was just like the prophet
sallam was a strong masculine man right
now this the I remember when I wrote
from my sister's lips I talk about the
Stepford wife's uh you know narrative
right and this idea that you know to be
a woman is to to be weak and to be a man
is to be strong no both men and women
can be weak and strong but our strength
is exhibited differently right and Allah
made us like that so sisters understand
this the more you lean into your
masculine traits
the harder it will be for you to attract
and bond with a masculine man because a
masculine man does not want another
masculine in his life he wants the
polarity he needs the polarity he needs
the feminine similar that she she would
she wouldn't want someone that's imagine
imagine your husband comes home with
heels and lipstick on we're gonna say oh
look that's how we see I'll be on this
when you see a masculine a woman that's
how we see it's as good as you've seen
your husband dressed up in heels and
wearing a lipstick and got a long hair
or something like that yeah so dude
you'll be like that's how we feel
yeah yeah exactly so this is not again
about feminism red pill anything this is
literally what is the blueprint that our
Dean gives us and if you look at
again she's been her story has been used
to further a feminist boss babe
narrative and it's disingenuous it is
it's not correct okay the the and and
the parts that people are ignoring
people are ignoring those parts because
they are not comfortable with the
feminine role they are not comfortable
and grateful for and satisfied with the
feminine role which is that of support
of helpmate of mother of wife of Rock
when he needs it okay oh you know all of
those things that we that we know that
Allah tells us you know this is this is
the best of wives okay all of those
Hadith that talk about you know how the
man should be with his wife
if you want a man who's like that then
you have to be the woman that is
described in the Quran Hadith you know
you can't come with your boss babe
energy and your modern girl
sensibilities and your feminist uh your
brainwashing and expect somebody to come
and be all Sunnah with you like it's not
gonna happen it's not gonna work it's
not going to work as well I just wanna I
just want to say this point because it
is really important if they're any older
um people listening
be careful of how you're raising your
sons and daughters because what's
happening it's like the pendulum has
swung right there was a time when girls
were you know had to serve everybody and
their education wasn't important and
they were always being told wives
mothers wives mothers get married get
married right so then from that the
pendulum swung the other way so now the
girls are being pushed to get educated
to get into great careers and to do
really well for themselves and they're
doing it masha'allah right what's
happening as a result the girls are
outperforming the boys the girls are
overqualified for the boys that are
there and the boys are under qualified
right the girls are full of confidence
the boys have no confidence and the
girls masculine and their girls are
masculine as anything right and they're
hoping that someone's going to come and
know you have to match my energy you
know you have to match you have to match
me you have to come be at my level girl
your parents your parents out there be
careful when you're raising these sassy
daughters you're creating a headache not
just for them in their future but also
any man that wants to become close to
her and if you're raising your sons
and you're kind of diminishing their
role in the family diminishing their
responsibilities diminishing their
mahram duties for example right
diminishing their say in the household
all you're doing is emasculating him so
now you've got a masculine daughter and
a feminized son and now you wonder why
no one's getting married and there's no
grandchildren and like the whole thing
is messed up there is a list of there's
a there's a lack of tobacco all these
issues all of these issues this is why
like I'm launching the app because they
all go back to tokid they all go back to
tohit everything that we have enough in
this the problems that we have they all
go back to tokid everything you can
mention whatever you like to me I'll
connect it back to lack of token it's a
lack of tawako that's why these parents
are saying go to go get education do
your degree so if that husband that you
know they're really preparing them for
divorce once you get divorced you look
at the look at this world why it's as if
there is zero tawako now this doesn't
mean of course you might marry someone
who might be evil whatever it may be tie
your camel forget we've gone past the
entire camel you have broke your camels
back forget about you come with a strong
because there is no put your trust in
Allah it's tie your camel and they've
tied it to such a degree that Camel is
dead now instead it's not grieving and
you're like now I put my trust in Allah
yeah brother now you come to dead by the
way so the point is there is in the
water exactly and the thing is here
and this is the truth now there's
another woman to study no but one thing
that needs to be clear what this is
within a woman's nature the hypergamous
by Nature they if if a woman is a doctor
she is not going to marry an Uber driver
I mean I used to be an Uber driver I
don't I don't even remember having uh
you know my pursuit of marriage I don't
ever think I'm a doctor yeah so the
thing is here is that they want someone
that is someone that is above them or
like the same degree so this shows that
at the end of the day they're getting
older in the sense where they're leaving
they're doing their career first and
then they reach in their 30s it's such a
Wallah is such a pro of shaytan if
you're clever you would have Mary Young
get your kids when they reached the age
of 10 12 in their teens then go back to
work they do it the opposite way round
and when it's that 30s alarm bells oh my
gosh I need to get married I'm getting
old well hello there it's like as if any
time we do things against the Sunnah we
always suffer and we need to understand
the more educated you are the less this
is by your nature buy your nature as a
woman which it goes back to what you
said in the beginning that it's the
woman that should kind of not cater to
men but I understand that psychology you
know because at the end of the day if
you run after then because with
Indonesia because ninety percent of time
or 80 of the time they are initiating
divorce a man a man is not interested
which means it must be in the marriages
yeah I want to say I want to say this
that to this to this point
um for me you know again going back to
that initial video that we watched
I firmly believe that a woman shows up
best and in her most beautiful feminine
when she's with a man that she feels
grateful for right that she is happy to
be with
he is like the best thing out there
right that that's it for me okay
um and and that's why
if you are not if she doesn't see you
like that if she doesn't see you she's
not she's not a good candidate because
literally she she could take you or
leave you basically like okay fine
whatever and in that kind of situation a
woman does not she doesn't have the same
sense of loyalty and devotion and and
kind of this is my man like this is a
return and you know I'm this I'm in this
for life right
um and that's a problem that's a problem
for us how we show up and it's also a
problem for our husbands but going back
to uh you know to to the whole marriage
thing I had a really wonderful
conversation with some some young
sisters uh my friend's daughters
actually and they had come to a marriage
event and they were not event like a
talk about marriage and you know they
sat me down and they said look at the
moment I'm really happy you know I
finished my my a levels I did my degree
I've got a great job I live at home I've
got wonderful friends you know I'm
traveling like my life is really good
right now why should I want to get
married and again this is the this is
the Trap of the Dunya to be honest right
because the the better things are it's
what is that that that straight that
quote that they say that hard times
create strong men strong men create easy
times Time created men create you know
all of that yeah yeah yeah something
like that and I think I think the same
is with women right is you know if you
know being paid pairing with somebody
and starting your own home is is is
almost on the level of survival for you
your attitude towards is going to be
completely different but now we're in a
situation where well I could take it or
leave it and all I said to these young
ladies was and I'll say this to the
audience as well just take it from me
I'm in my 40s now handling this is 23
masha'allah you know we always talking
about marriage and all of this type of
thing because that's what's on the
horizon for them
but what I said to them is
you have invested already several years
in your education
if you'd invest the next five to ten
years in your career
all you'll have at the end of these 15
so 10 15 years is maybe a house okay
maybe Money in the Bank
loads of memories a great Instagram feed
and that's it
that's it this is not an investment in
your future because right now mashallah
you got your degree right you you're
confident in yourself on the line like
you're at that stage you're an adult
you're able to take responsibility Etc
if you invested the next 10 to 15 years
of your life in a family
that is a true investment because you're
pairing with somebody you're going to
create your own home inshallah you're
going to have children while you're nice
and young and fresh and full of energy
and those children are your investment
that's your future and I know some
people get triggers all kids are not an
investment and they are they are that's
how Allah created us yeah stop all this
nonsense about you know children no they
are that's your line that's your lineage
right that's you know essentially your
reason for living your reason for being
a couple for being a family is the next
Generation it's not about you anymore
it's not just about you as an individual
and how you feel it's like you know what
you and me Suleiman whatever his name is
Allah has given us this Amana he's
blessed us with this this this amazing
Amana this this massive job of raising
the next generation of Muslims let's do
our best with the with this let us
let's Tire ourselves out for this
purpose this is real this is Legacy this
is right so I said to her
you can't have it both ways you can't
and I will say this to young women again
and again and again you cannot have it
all
so you can either spend from 18 to 28
good 10 years investing in your career
and your personal development and your
professional development and your
financial status and all of that and at
the end of that 28 or 35 wherever you
are may or may not find the right man
for you and be able to have a family
because that is the risk that you run
and it's a very real risk right this is
what Jordan Peterson talked about when
he talked about you know the this this
generation of women that are going to be
unmarried and childless right when
you're in your 20s it's all fun and
games right exactly it's it's traveling
it's traveling it's you know not having
that much responsibility because maybe
you're still living at home you know
it's buying bags and shoes and all of
this stuff it's not so pretty when you
get to your 30s and it's even worse when
you get to your 40s so don't let you
know social media or advertising or
films lie to you and tell you that you
can live that single girl life and have
an amazing time and then still get the
guy at the end still get the family that
you may want at the end of it you're
better off taking your life and yourself
seriously if you want to be married if
you want to have a family that should be
one of your life goals don't be ashamed
of that because girls nowadays and
people in general nowadays I've heard
people say getting married is not like
being married is not Flex
like it's not an accomplishment to be
married and I was like really
well how come what do you mean and the
reason they say that is because there
are people who haven't managed to do it
so sisters who haven't managed to get
married if you say marriage is an
accomplishment then you're making them
feel bad because they didn't manage to
get married it's like yeah but but
that's that's father of Allah firstly
but it is a fail
right it is what it is right if you
wanted to have children and you were not
able to have children then you did not
achieve your objective I thought of
Allah but you didn't achieve it that's a
fact and you have to deal with that but
my point is this
wanting to be married and you know you
have to ask yourself right do I want to
be married do I want to have children if
you do don't put all your other
aspirations first and expect there to be
marriage at the end of the rainbow you
need to be working towards being
someone's wife being wife material you
know being a mother one day at the same
rate that you're working towards your
Bachelors your Masters your first 10K on
Instagram which out of whatever is here
it needs to be part of your
Consciousness because otherwise it's
going to be left to chance it's going to
be left right to the end and it may or
may not happen for you and for some
people they're cool with that but a lot
of people are not cool with that and
they don't know how to articulate that I
had a sister who messaged me sorry I'm
going on a little bit here oh no please
no please please a sister who message me
subhanallah you know and she had reached
her 40s never married no children and
now she wants a husband and she doesn't
just want a husband for companionship
and she doesn't want to be a second wife
she wants a family she wants children
and my heart broke for her because I was
like this like you know most men when
they reach that stage or if they're
interested in a woman of that age
they're not looking to have a family
they may have had a family already maybe
they're divorced and they don't want to
have young kids again and the thing is
when we dug a little bit deeper she said
I hated men for a long time
and I allowed the marriages that I saw
around me to to to to make me kind of
shut off from men that did approach me
and their proposals that came so I put
off and put it off and put it off until
now here I am at 40 and I don't know
whether it's gonna happen for me that is
a very very sad place to find yourself
and if people are not are not thinking
and are not careful they could find
themselves in that place and really
there's not much that anyone can say to
them at that point because guess what it
doesn't look so cool anymore it doesn't
feel so great anymore and they try and
lie
and say yeah you're going to be the rich
Auntie you know you're a rich one die
alone with your riches in your home all
of this superficial materialistic
garbage human beings need connection
exactly
right human beings we're not you know
yeah anyway exactly
I will definitely have you on the bitter
trip show because there's so much A lot
of people need to hear this and this
that's the reality you know if their
sister's watching this and brothers as
well we spoke about that as well well
you need to understand it's a delusion
you know to be in like because it's like
you're just in a delusion where your
young men are approaching you you think
that's going to last forever this is
what the biggest issue is that a lot of
sisters are realizing that when the time
is over and they start panicking and you
should have prepared for that day before
like we said before Allah has created
woman in that manner you know
biologically the time runs out faster
subhanallah for a man he gets more
established towards 30s or sisters yes
you can do your career okay do a degree
where you finish about 23 whatever it
may be but seek marriage at early age
find a good husband somebody who is good
inshallah and invest in that wallahi let
me tell you something
having kids having inshallah you have a
good husband but having kids there is
nothing on this Earth that would ever
replace that and believe me once you
have your kids you know what you will
say you will say I don't know how life
was without them it was such a boring
life I mean how was life without these
my kids
what degree uh this bag would not it's
Wildlife let me tell you something trust
me you know like my wife is a teacher
you know she's she's a teacher
um and the the same thing like I look at
her now and while I'll be honest with
her like she's she's so happy she's I've
never heard of one saying like for
example yeah after this or I'm gonna you
know she doesn't even mention whatever
discussion there's and there's nothing
wrong if you want to do it like
part-time as long as it doesn't get in
the way of certain stuff it's fine but
one lie I just see her just she loves it
just seeing my just seeing her feeding
our daughter it's as if like they're
giving the whole Dunya to her she's like
I just love it when she's hungry I mean
when she's yeah
it might sound crazy but even when she
goes yeah when my mother obvious you
know when she poops yeah like even she's
like it's for a woman looking for a
mother it's like oh her bowel's working
I'm thinking about his thinks well look
to me he's like yeah so here it to her
is like alhamdulillah like it's like
it's like somebody's giving a golden a
plate I'm like I'm running away like I'm
like no I can't do that that nappy I
can't do I'm so sorry uh the the number
one I can number two that's all about
you yeah but I'm seeing as a mother I'm
thinking how is she saw like I'm seeing
the change is nothing she's got a smile
on the face I'm thinking how'd you do
that like this is a smell she's like
nice it's beautiful so it was like I'm
like wow that to me I don't understand
that Allah has created her with such a
rahma mercy that when I smell before
open the nappy I'm leaving the room I'm
like yeah that's my shop yeah but to her
you're gonna get all the comments and
all the smoke now yeah all the smoke
how amazing
how amazing subhanallah and that's it
well guys inshallah if you would like to
see more reaction videos with myself and
sister Naima please let us know just
send this video so we can do that but we
are going to have a on the bitter trip
showing Charlotte with we started
re-filming around end of June June or
July or maybe around August inshallah uh
we would have Cincinnati if there's
specific topics you would like us to
cover
on the bitter troop show we'll set the
Neymar please let us know inshallah and
that's it do not forget to check the
link of Cincinnati the the book um
your story Message or knowledge into a
book yes that's it you want to put your
story Message or knowledge into a book
and you don't know where to start and
you don't know where to go next please
inshallah I would love to be your coach
so just click the link in the
description and get in touch and let's
see if we can make something happen
inshallah
not brothers and sisters I said sisters
and brothers
[Laughter]
yeah so anyways till next time
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a Savage for you
because every person that comes a step
closer to Allah through your donation
award click the link and donate what you
can